-Guys, it's time to play the game that's sweeping the nation.
It's...
[ Audience cheers ]
-This is the game where we pick a random audience member
and guess if there's a 'stache under their mask.
We've done it a few times on the show.
It's sweeping the nation. -Sweeping the nation.
-Yeah, so let's please welcome tonight's audience member,
Ishon Parmar.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Nice to see you. Welcome.
Alright. This is very good.
Ishon, where are you from?
-Los Altos, California.
-Hey. Los Altos, California.
Alright. That's all I can ask you.
-Cool. -That's all I can ask you.
Right now we have to figure out
if you have a 'stache under that mask.
Tariq, you're going to go first, bud.
You can ask him one question,
but then you have to make your guess.
-If -- If I took a piece of tape, masking tape,
you know, electrical tape,
and taped it down on your upper lip,
and then snatched it off really hard,
would it be painful,
very painful, or would it be not so painful?
-Not so painful.
I'm pretty -- I've got a high pain tolerance.
-Ooh. -Hmm!
-Yeah. -That's a zero.
-Tariq, what's your guess?
-I'm going to say no 'stache.
-Gotcha. Alright, Higgins, your turn.
Everyone's waiting. What is your question?
-Everyone's waiting for me? -The world is.
-Well, then I'll hurry up.
I won't take any time to ask this question.
The question's going to come out now.
I'm not wasting anybody's time.
I'm going to ask Ishon a question. This question is...
-Something you thought of? -Yeah, I thought of this
question to determine if you have a 'stache or not.
-And you're not gonna waste any time.
-No, I don't want to waste time. People got stuff to do.
I don't want to waste these people's time.
-Oh. Very good. We appreciate that. Thank you.
-New York City! Come on! [ Cheers and applause ]
-We appreciate it. We appreciate it.
-If you were, say -- Not that you would.
But if you were to write a paper on pornography, let's say...
-Oh.
-...would you write it on the '70s brand or modern day?
-Hm. -That is my question to you.
-I'm on the younger side, so I'd say the modern day.
-Oh, okay.
I got this. -Okay. What do you think?
-I've got this.
Because it's been zig-zagging away from the questions.
Pain tolerance. Younger side.
I'm going to say 'stache.
-Wow. You're going the opposite way.
-Yeah. -You're thinking 'stache.
Alright. It's my turn. Here we go.
-Are you going to ask him a question?
-Mm-hmm.
When you eat chili... -Ooh.
-...do you kind of smell it all day?
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, yes.
-Well, that could be because he has gas.
[ Laughter ]
Or a stomach issue. You know what I mean?
He's trying to trick you.
-Uh, that's interesting. I'm really close.
But I will say he's got decent sideburns
that I can see.
So I'm going to say...
I think he has a 'stache.
-We got two 'stache. -And one no stache.
Alright. Here we go. It's time to find out...
-Audience: Is there a 'stache under that mask?!
[ Drum roll ]
-Oh! Yeah!
♪♪
-Look at that. That's what I'm talking about.
I love that! He does have a 'stache!
For playing, you won a year's supply of Turtle Wax.
Turtle Wax. When you're here, you're family.
This has been "Is There a 'Stache Under That Mask?"
We'll be right back with more "Tonight Show." Come on back.